herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
heute sind wir bei dem du und wir sind
auf play meine team wir machen heute
jetzt wo ich bin ich bin eine challenge
und zwar die fünf checkpoint challenge
ganz einfach wir gehen auf die map und
ich darf es in dieser runde nur fünf
checkpoints mitnehmen dankeschön
der friseur oder fünf von uns mitnimmt
wenn ich ein checkpoint mehr mitnehmen
dann ist weniger berechtigt mir für jede
weitere checks konnte nicht mitnehmen
eine chance zu geben
jetzt fragt ihr euch so versinken nur
fünf checkpoints ist noch zehn in der
runde korrekt aber es gibt eine
möglichkeit die checkpoints zu
überlaufen auch ohne sie auszulösen und
das liegt daran dass die platte nur
sieben achtel des blocks 1 im 3 also
nicht den ganzen glocken wir mal ganz
außen am rand lang läuft kann man
schaffen und das problem jetzt erst mal
das was die ganze sache nämlich deutlich
deutlich schwieriger leute fünf mal habe
ich jetzt mit ihm das heißt ja fünf mal
die druckplatte auslösen ich glaube ganz
ehrlich bei so einem puren checkpoint am
anfang wirklich nicht erst das modul
direkt ausgelöst hier habe ich noch
ich würde ich springe aber nach außen
gab
das modul ist auch relativ safe
eigentlich auch wenn sie hier bis 13 45
die blöcke weg genommen haben jetzt
gehts auch hierunter auch verändert aber
dafür muss man nicht mehr so weit
reinbeißen und ja sollen wir jetzt kurz
den ultimativen jump electric enthüllen
wir gezeigt dass ein geheimnis lassen
der ultimative jump liegt trick schafft
ihr diesen ultimativen jump league blitz
und ja scheiß drauf dass nämlich mit
wieder weil sich zwei check points
die sache ist nämlich leute wenn ihr ein
modul auf tour den checkpoint auszulösen
und dann im modul danach runterfällt
wenn es sinn macht werden natürlich zwei
module resetten drin ich gesagt hab
keinen scheck von ausgelöst hat und das
kann durchaus weh tun
deswegen muss jetzt dem auslösen wenn
sie seitlich an springen musste ich auch
diese kosten auf die probleme erst mal
nein wahrscheinlich schon bei 70 prozent
ja diese schweine mit ihren freiherr von
maydell es gibt keine verlierer noch
ablegen jaja sinnvollerweise ich meine
ich meinen text highlighter herzlich
willkommen sondern ein alter ok-chef
punktgleich mit mir ganz so seitliches
hat ricky habe ich nehme jetzt aber mit
zwei habe ich schon ausgelöst
12 das ist kein zuckerschlecken sage ich
mal kein zucker spielen ja gut
jetzt muss ich aber hier eigentlich
auflösen wenn das aber wenn das budget
ist aber ich kann ein bisschen dann ist
allerdings egal
ok doppelsprung machen und das ziel
danach ist relativ kurz oder nicht ich
weiß ich ich mir sagt das mit onyx ich
glaube es ist ein neues aber lautet
unser glück als ich also den ersten mal
mehr als vier sprung bei smart xl nehmen
ja okay okay
alter schwede jetzt könnt ihr vielleicht
natürlich alles klar oder wie ist die
lage ruhig alles gut als interessant
wenn jetzt ist der typ das einfach noch
nicht gepackt hat das zu finishen
der war vor über 67 prozent vj 3 war es
72 prozent also dann tatsächlich ist
okay ich bin gespannt
das habe ich noch nie gespielt dass mir
das nun 33 ich meine leute 3er ist nicht
schlecht also ich würde drei mitnehmen
das ist ja nicht aber okay das da vorne
kenne ich einfach natürlich
aber das erste war es der letzte
ich wollte nicht auslösen
ab jetzt wird gefeiert was aber ist das
kenne ich nicht kenne ich natürlich
gegen drei weit 1 hoch auf die kiste
hast aber so weit müssen wir nochmal das
boot schicken als theoretisch alles klar
dass überhaupt noch bei dem modul
dahinter nein
ok also man muss jetzt aufpassen dass
ich will nicht riskieren sonst trifft
einen die taunus faust
besonders vom ersten runde
juni nvidia die junge yuma es könnte ich
könnte ich immer sein dass der jetzigen
sich aber denkt häufig auf die welt und
die angst davor dass das ist das classic
inspizieren wieso junge meister ich
denke so okay man sagen ich mich mal so
als könnte ich können die wissenschaften
ran machen alles easy alles super wie
cool sein wenn das warum ist es so
schwer
laufen ich habe es nicht schätzen sie
mal gesprungen ich weiß nicht was daran
lag aber vielleicht noch später mal was
passt ja okay okay der fall kommt
vielleicht kommt das nicht kann
ich habe eine checkliste totti marcus
monk stört sich auch kurz sogar ohne
drehen sich hin rosten christian hat
getroffen
das hört der wm natürlich weil er keine
kopfhörer auf hat aber ich höre das
offenbar weniger welche köpfe auf dem
scheiß erhält somit die mitspieler
umgegangen über köpfen raus aus der zwei
herzen
alter schwede sie durch ein balkon mit
drop ist wieso uns essen screen spieler
ohne witz und jetzt ist der will nicht
mehr
jährigen alter leute auf der man früher
mal informatikraum cs go gespielt in der
schule nicht okay aber ich hab mich so
weit davor gedrückt zu sterben die sonne
und das eingebrockt wollt ihr euch
gegenseitig angreifen sollte ich mein
erster gewinnen können der gabriel
er ist ja genau das boxen sich doch 2
wenn zwei sich boxen freut sich der es
ist ja wohl leider klappt man muss ein
bisschen zweiten habe ich das irgendwie
passen beleidigung über den chat
schreiben könnte aber das wird man sehen
so wie du es ja wenig da können wir
eigentlich okay alles klar
ich muss schon mal begleitet meine
mutter beleidigt zuschauer youtuber
youtuber heckt youtube staubt ab
youtuber macht youtube enthüllt alter
denn er läuft aber auch so schlecht
natürlich überlegt videos auf web video
plattform youtube hat internetanschluss
als ob es das schon war 92 gegen das von
bei leben was ist das und die neustadt
das war die fünf checkpoint challenge
bei mir bei wenig und auch eine folge
wären wir sehr gespannt ob das besser
machen kann als ich aber vielleicht mehr
stellen kassiert längst den videos in
der beschreibung
gestern hat rein